Viewer driven narratives, on the other hand, take a very different approach.
Rather than dictating a specific narrative,
it allows our user to freely interact with the data, and tell their own story.
This is the excellent crime-spotting visualization, created by Statement Design.
Here, there's no specific ordering a particular narrative.
Instead, the data's presented to the viewer with various filters for
zoom level, time of day, time of week, and various crimes.
Let's say I live in the Mission, and
I want to look at crime during my walk home from the Bart station everyday.
Let's go ahead and zoom in there.
I use the 16th Street in Mission Bart.
So, we'll zoom it no this particular area.
I'm only re, really worried about days of the week where I work, so
I'll select Monday through Friday.
I typically get home between 6 PM and midnight, so let's go ahead and
select that there.
We can see here that there are two thefts,
a narcotics, and simple assault violations in this area.
I can click into each one of these and
get more information about the particular crime.
With a few simple interactions, this visualization allowed me to ask a question
that was important to me, and tell my own story with this particular data set.
Another example of a viewer-driven visualization is Paths to the White House,
also by the New York Times.
Here we're presented with a decision tree that highlights the outcome of
the presidential election,
given how each candidate fares in key swing states like Florida.
The overarching narrative is presented in the beginning.
That Obama has 84% of the paths to win, while Romney only has 15%.
But the viewer is invited to explore various outcomes by mousing over
the different paths.
If I'm interested in a particular swing state, such as Ohio,
I could see that if Romney wins Florida and Obama wins Ohio, Obama wins.
This is a great example of a hybrid between an overarching narrative and
a viewer-driven visualization.
This allows the viewer to mouse through and
look at each aspect of the data, and tell their own particular story.